this talk I will describe how
crowdsourcing can be used in personal
information management crowdsourcing has
been able to do some pretty amazing
things and I will start with some
examples garden in 1907 that's about 100
years ago went to a farmer fair where
800 farmers competed to get the guests
there to get the weight of an ox and not
a single one guessed it right but what's
impressive is that the average of all
dresses were was only one pound away
from the exact weight this is an example
of the wisdom of the crowd where
independence of many estimates can
provide results that no individual can
over the last decade crowd sourcing
patterns have created mark much more
complex ways to change these estimates
together to be able to solve even more
challenging tasks for example this
totally legible text was deciphered by
online workers using iterative
refinement researchers have even created
plug-ins for Microsoft Word to provide
crowd powered grama are checking and
summarization of text and with things
like Wikipedia people coordinate at a
scale accuracy and keep it up 2day in a
way that is that no centralized
organization has been able to do in the
past research has shown that remote
online workers can be organized in such
ways to provide metadata structure and
to identify important information when
needed for example in a project that was
helping black blind people the blind
people were able to take pictures of
items they were interested to read and
the crowd was able to read the labels of
those items back to them now that we've
seen some of the achievements of
crowdsourcing can crowdsourcing help us
help us manage our personal information
for example email overload and task
management in this thesis I apply
crowdsourcing to email overload and task
management people are overloaded on both
aspects because management requires
planning decision-making and it consumes
willpower
so people tend to postpone this planning
and as a result they miss deadlines or
they fail to complete goals and
expectations and there's big unsolved
problems in the existing literature how
to effectively apply crowdsourcing in
personal information management and even
if you do that how to address privacy
and accountability concerns for private
user data in this dissertation I'm
introducing the genies pattern for
organizing and scaling crowd-sourced
work the valley pattern for addressing
privacy and accountability concerns and
i instantiate those two patterns in in a
couple of systems email voluntas teenies
i'm also using these systems to so
experimental evidence that external this
external organization is helpful to
people and that crowdsourcing is an
effective way to provide it email valet
is an email client that automatically
extract tasks from people's inboxes and
ask Xena season as a to-do list program
that provides action plans to two tasks
so that people can complete them more
easily I will start with email valet the
valet crowdsourcing approach and
behavioral findings from this too then I
will talk about as genus the genus
pattern and the related findings we want
to extend crowdsourcing such that people
feel comfortable sharing personal
information with assistance and to do
that I'm going to introduce the idea of
valet crowdsourcing if a lucky for a car
is a key that can give access to a
driver only two to open the door or
maybe start the engine but it doesn't
let them access the trunk or the glove
compartment of the car so this key is
effectively giving two guarantees one is
that it limits functionality the driver
can't get into your trunk but it also
establishes accountability so the driver
is responsible for the car car while
they have the key but not before or
after and this is a really nice
interface actually because it's simple
and
clear to everyone similarly while a
crowdsourcing parsimoniously gives
assistance just enough access to do most
of the work without giving them access
to all user data second it seeks act to
establish accountability by making
access boundaries transparent and by
designing access logs so that
transgressions are recorded and the
crowd workers are held responsible for
their actions to understand would let us
to Valley crowdsourcing let's look at
the email overload prior research has
found that people spend a lot of time to
transform their overwhelming in boxes to
actions they need to take in this inbox
the important tasks are just in these
few emails it would be nice if I could
see only those five emails and even
better if I could see the actual tasks
because that would give me time to save
me time to that I have to reread and
remember what the tasks are in those
emails for example there is a there's an
email there with a subject will be full
soon and that really means that I need
to buy a new hard drive for the server
but would you feel comfortable giving
crowd workers access to your inbox to
extract those tasks for you well we
surveyed 500 years residents and less
than four percent of them was willing to
share they were worried about privacy
and accountability one informant said
I'd want some liability insurance for
what a rogue assistant might do with my
information so while a crowdsourcing is
trying to address exactly these problems
and we created email valet as
instantiation of this gmail valid comets
the first is the first application of
email valet it's an email client that
gives access to the same emails that you
have in gmail but it has two interfaces
one interfaces for users where they can
see everything and they can perform the
usual actions that you do with your
email and another interface is the
interface for assistance and in that
interface you get access to only a
limited subset of your inbox
they the assistants can perform only
limited subset of the actions based on
the user's preferences and all actions
of assistants are recorded also email
valet has a task list interface it
incorporates that right into your inbox
so the assistants extract tasks for you
and you can accept or decline those
extractions and you can add any missing
tasks to build better common ground we
when when when a user declines the task
then they can the system offers them
over seemed the ability to leave a note
so that they can tell the reason why
they climb they declined the task here
we see a user reading emails and
exacting tasks and clicking on the
various tasks to see which emails
they're coming from so for privacy
assistants have no access to user
passwords they cannot search old emails
in fact they can only see the last ex
emails from a person's inbox where X
could be 100 for example 24 further the
peace of mind users can restrict access
to only emails that are in priority
inbox or that have stars or that image
that they have sent to themselves and
they could even restrict it to emails
that have a special label assistant
possibly using gmail filters to select
those and for further peace of mind the
there is a there's their block their
specific there's a specific option where
the users can specify block keywords for
example an email address or a name or a
domain name
and emails that contain those keyboard
key words are always invisible by the
assistance for example someone can put
the name of his girlfriend or the bank
account name and they know that even if
those emails where would be visible due
to the other rules they wouldn't be
visible because of the of this feature
finally for a special block keyword is
default to everyone and this prevents
from somebody else's assistant see a
private message that you're sending to
them you can include that keyword and
you know that it is in his block list
users decide what assistant what actions
the assistants can take for example they
decide whether the assistant can archive
delete reply or start messages and
whether they can manage tasks for
transparency emails are visible emails
that are visible two assistants are
clearly marked from on the inbox and
assistant actions are always recorded
here's a screenshot with one email
selected we can see those preview icons
on the inbox directly so messages that
are visible two assistants have a human
icon and messages that are not visible
the assistants have a lock icon hovering
over these icons reveals the reason why
the system made this visibility choice
and by clicking on the icon itself it
overrides that assistant actions are
also displayed here in our system has
extracted a couple of tasks for one of
the emails
a record of all actions is visible along
with the message details right here and
in a separate view you can see that a
complete log file in a controlled
experiment we tested whether email valet
helps people complete email based tasks
and how people adopted Valley sharing it
was a within-subjects design with 28
participants they were assisted by three
crowd or desk workers the study had
three conditions counterbalanced in a
Latin square manner so the conditions
were control self and valet to describe
the conditions I will say that the
assistants extracted tasks for all
participants for all conditions but
these tasks were hidden from the
participants during the control and self
phases in the control condition people
just used email in the traditional way
in the self condition they were
encouraged to extract their own tasks
out of email set and in the valley
condition they received the full the
full email valet assistance the measures
in this study were assistant accuracy
and completion rate we gathered these by
asking participants at the end of its
condition to correct the task
extractions that were made by the
assistance and to mark all completed
tasks they study concluded with a survey
to explore reactions to valet
crowdsourcing let's look at some of the
results first participants completed
twice as many tasks in the valet
condition compared to the other two also
the assistant task extraction accuracy
improved over time from sixty-five
percent up to eighty-five percent at the
end of the study and the cost of the
system was relatively inexpensive it
costs about two dollars a day per user
even at an eight dollar per hour wait
for the assistance but how do people
react to valet crowdsourcing well we
expected that would be very reserved in
sharing but we found out that nearly
everyone share that lists
part of their inbox with automatic value
filters in fact only two participants
hand-picked messages to show to the
assistants at the end only three people
said that they would stop using email
valet for privacy reasons the majority
of participants 18 initially felt
uncomfortable with with sharing but 11
of them reported that they were feeling
more comfortable over time and that
finding is really reinforcing the belief
that privacy is a dynamic dialectic
process when the benefit exceeds the
invasion people are willing to share
information they previously considered
private one participant said originally
I did not say our emails from my
boyfriend but I changed that after
realizing he sent me emails with tasks
for me to do another one said by
uneasiness reduced over time as I was
impressed with the accuracy of correct
tasks generated for me assistants also
shared some discomfort one assistant
said some emails I felt like I was
invading their privacy because I it was
emails between my clients and their
family but I didn't react anyway because
it's a job I have to do as we saw email
valet has plenty of elements to support
accountability however these were not
the most frequently used features of the
system but the mere fact that they exist
increase the comfort for the users and
adoption for the for the system to recap
I presented a first use of crowd-sourced
expert assistance to support personal
information management valet
crowdsourcing that seeks to balance
privacy and accountability for sensitive
data the immobilized system for email
task management and empirical results
that crowd assistants can manage
information accurately email relax
tasks from in boxes but how do people
complete their tasks and how can the
crowd help them complete more tasks
that's exactly what does Cena see
studying a major issue with the task
execution is that high level tasks are
not actionable and people delay doing
them Michael slackin Ernie from phd
comics has a to-do list that contains a
bunch of concrete tasks and one
high-level task work on thesis as time
goes by he completes all of his concrete
tasks but his high-level task lingers in
the end he declares bankruptcy and
creates a new task list that contains
steal that lingering high-level task
researchers studied the importance of
forming action plans through another
experiment as well they talked to
students the university students about
the benefits of a flu shot but they
divided the students into two classrooms
in one room they just talked about the
benefits in the other room they also
talked about ask them to creat to form
action plans on how they're going to get
that shot and they found that students
in that room got the shot more
frequently so just to be clear an action
plan is simply a list of steps to
complete a task for example in the task
exercise frequently and actually a
possible action plan can be get a gym
membership create a weekly exercise
schedule and find the workout body to
keep you accountable let's look at some
of the benefits of creating action plans
as we saw people get more efficient with
smaller steps to act on also completing
those intermediate steps is rewarding
and it's easier to make smaller
decisions on how to proceed when you
have smaller steps to to do finally
people are more productive when they are
interrupted between steps than during
steps so
having those action plans provides a
good in interruption moment it's the
time you mark off a small task on your
list however planning takes time right
away whereas the benefits of planning
come later so people often fail to plan
can technology help provide those plans
automatically and if that's possible do
those plans help or is it the act of
contemplating the plans yourself that
provides the benefit here's a sketch of
completion rate against convenience not
creating action plans is convenient
because you don't have to do it but it's
less productive as we saw and creating
action plans it is / quiz more
productive but it's inconvenient because
you have to create them could we combine
the benefits from both with
automatically provided action plans and
that's the main hypothesis of nastiness
that yes providing action plans helps
people complete tasks and that
crowdsourcing is an effective way to do
it plans exist for some domains for
example recipes instructables see how
and you can even search or create your
own but all that takes time and effort
and that's exactly what we want to avoid
here that's Jamie's is it to do list
that automatically decomposes people's
tasks to action plans on the left you
can enter tasks and subtasks like a SAT
like a tree and on the right you see
action plan recommendations
automatically generated for you we do
that using Amazon Mechanical Turk
workers to create the action plans and
NLP techniques to reuse existing ones
when possible just to clarify that
Amazon Mechanical Turk is a community of
about 200,000 online workers who execute
chunks of work for small payments for
example the they are effective at
labeling images or in our case for
creating acts
plans here is a preview of the
crowdsourcing interface of das genies
but I will end up we'll talk more about
it a bit later to create action plans we
tried using very simple crowdsourcing
patterns and we found problems so we
created a fourth pattern the genies
pattern to address these problems let's
look at these buttons one at a time we
started with a parallel pattern in the
parallel pattern all workers a square
ask to independently create action plans
and in the end the peak they rated and
they picked the best the results where
the results as in many as in many cases
in we seen Amazon Mechanical Turk there
was a lot of spam or low quality in
independent contributions also because
everybody was working independently the
good ideas from one worker could not
propagate to the plants of other workers
and we even saw that many of the workers
were providing solutions to the wrong
problem and here's an example of that
for the task read the rest of the hidden
reality which is a book one worker broke
it down into its words and another try
to execute the task no matter what no
matter what we changed in the
description of the that we provided that
didn't help we we realized that the more
text we add the the worse the results
are the less people read it probably in
the serial approach the first worker
creates a plan the second worker it
improves that plan based on the improves
the plan of the first worker and the
third worker continues on the second
workers work and so on and so forth this
creates multiple versions and the best
one is selected in the end well in this
pattern we we still didn't see much
improvement in quality and we even
further so a new problem
which was fixation to early ideas
sometimes the first worker would provide
the bad idea and then everyone would
just improve on that here's an example
for the same task read the rest of the
hidden reality the first worker created
read chapter one two three it's up to
four to six and so on and so forth and
then following workers improved it to
read chapter one started so to combine
the benefits from both approaches we
created a revising approach which in the
beginning it asked workers to
independently like in the parallel
approach create action plans after they
created an action plan the the workers
were displayed all the versions of other
action plans created by other workers
and then too they were asked to revise
their own if they if they wanted in the
end the best was selected with rating um
visa technique actually gave us better
quality and we saw that good idea is
propagated but they actually propagated
slowly because probably because people
had already completed their work when
they were asked to look at the examples
and they rarely revised their own work
it was already done so he was still a
wasteful and expensive way to produce
the plans to solve all these problems we
created the genius pattern that is
composed of three phases great
contemplate and synthesize and I will
explain those right away so we still
need ratings to determine the best
solutions and instead of putting these
ratings at the end of the work of the
worker we we put them at the beginning
but to avoid fixation too bad due to
fixation I like in the serial approach
we asked workers to rate action plans of
different tasks than the one they were
supposed to decompose here is a derating
face of Tazz genies for the readers of
the hidden reality task
several action plans can be seen on the
same script on the same page and were
workers rate the rate them to find the
good solution but these rating also
trains them and calibrate them on the
quality of that is expected it also
demonstrates in the upfront that work
will be assessed and how it will be
assessed and possibly this way these
weights some lazy workers from
continuing to encourage the independent
thinking we start workers start creating
their action plans for from a clean
slate and only in the middle of
producing their own solution they see
previous solutions of other workers on
the same problem this is the task genius
interface creating action plans the task
is shown at the top and steps are
entered at the bottom the workers think
conceptually come up with their own
solution enter the first step and the
moment is a bit the second step it's
when the synthesized phase begins this
is the moment where the worker has
entered his second step and he sees
independent related related steps from
other previous workers on this same task
since the worker has already
contemplated a solution and he has even
started creating it but he hasn't
finished he can easily identify good and
bad ideas on the solutions of other
workers and since he hasn't finished his
solution yet the activation energy to
integrate those good ideas is smoke
great ideas this way bubble up and
solutions converged to great solutions
very fast here is a drag and drop of a
good idea and editing a grammar mistake
of of that
as a reminder the main testing
hypothesis is that providing plans helps
people complete more tasks in a
between-subjects experiment we tested
exactly this hypothesis experiment had
280 participants and we asked them to
submit 20 tasks that they were planning
to complete in the near future one week
later we measured with how many tasks
this participants had actually completed
and we understand had the three
conditions the two main conditions were
control and crowd in the control we had
we applied no intervention in the crowd
we provided participants with action
plans and we son sent them those action
plans by email but sending those emails
serves as a reminder possibly for the
task and to control for the effect of
this reminder we created the third
condition prompt which sent participants
emails advising them to create their own
action plans and we sent those email
prompts at exactly the same time in wind
with a very similar wording than
compared to the to the crowd condition
we found that the participants who
received action plans completed more
tasks compared to all other groups with
statistical significance which supports
our tasks in his hypothesis but is
providing plans equally helpful to all
kinds of tasks for the example in the
PhD comic it is possible that high level
and veneering tasks can benefit more so
we asked participants to classify their
tasks as high level or not and old
lingering or new and we hypothesized
that providing plans help more with high
level than with small and well defined
tasks the results show that there is a
clear statistical significance between
this clear statistical is improvement
between crowd and control for the high
level tasks
and even though there is any there is
also an improvement for small and well
defined tasks it is marginally
significant which supports our
hypothesis and we also hypothesized that
providing plants helps lingering tasks
more than new tasks which we also found
true and this is a similar graph than
before that shows the similar effect in
some cases people enjoy giving each
other advice and they are really good at
it so a natural way to scale action plan
action plan provisioning is to have
users create plans for each other like a
community sourcing to test these
hypotheses as a second study was
conducted in this study we had the 380
88 people who again submitted to any
tasks and the study was very similar in
the end we measured the number of tasks
the number of tasks that people
completed and in this place we had two
conditions control which was the same as
in the previous study and community the
community was very similar to the crowd
condition of the previous study where
participants received action plans by
email but we also asked them during this
condition to create action plans for
others so in the end we measured as I
said that the number of tasks that
participants completed but also the
number of action plans that participants
contributed we found that community
created plants were also helpful
statistically significant results but
participants didn't contribute enough
this graph shows the distribution of
planned contribution are among
participants and interestingly we found
that the more plan participants created
for others the more plans they created
the cuit tasks they completed themselves
and this could mean that either
contributing is distracting or that the
procrastinators self selected to
contribute more instead of work
their own tasks certain studies we found
that we saw we just observed that people
have a lot of similar tasks for example
almost every participant had a cleaning
task and many participants wanted to
exercise more so here is a actually the
top 10 tasks among the tasks submitted
by 140 people cleaning buying calling
people paying bills are all very common
tasks so creating action plans for
similar tasks seems wasteful and we
hypothesize that reusing action plans
can also be helpful to people with
similar tasks for that reason we created
an NLP algorithm that identifies similar
tasks and automatically uses plans
across them and we use this algorithm to
run a third study to test the
reusability hypothesis the study had 39
participants to conditions recycle and
control in the recycle condition people
received their plants that were mostly
reused by from from before and in the
control condition it was the same no
intervention again we measured the
completion rates and the study found
that supported the hypothesis that the
reusing action plan plans helps
significantly increase task completion
rate just to give you a little more
understanding around the algorithm the
algorithm used a corpus of 6000 action
plans and we force matched ninety-five
percent of participant tasks to existing
plans and for the bottom five percent of
tasks for which the NL algorithm was the
least sewer about that it had found a
match we used the crowdsourcing to recap
the cheenies pattern strategically
presents examples of prior work to
increase quality the testing system is
leveraging crowd community and NLP to
provide action plans and we found that
automatically providing action plans
helps people complete more tasks and
combining crowd
algorithmic approaches we can provide
those plans to summarize this
dissertation found that crowds can
effectively organize and break down
personal information to help people be
more effective and I think this is just
one example where human computation can
improve knowledge work by helping people
focus on what's important and to avoid
information overload to do this we had
to invent a couple of things first we
needed a way to reliably get higher
quality plans and tasks from the crowd
so the genies pattern enable these
quality ideas second the concerns that
people had about turning their emails
into an assistant were very real so we
had to invent the valet method for
addressing privacy and accountability
going forward crowdsourcing can be
applied in many other areas of personal
information management calendar contact
lists and others and people's tasks not
only can be organized but you can even
get executed and crowdsourcing is not
even the only way for example tasks such
as by this book can be automatically
executed by an algorithm change the car
oil can be done by local workers plan my
trip to LA can be accomplished by own
line workers and choose a gift for a
birthday can be completed by peers
friends and family but more
crowdsourcing patterns are necessary how
can for example knowledge about an
individual be institutionalized in a
crowdsourcing system to provide quality
24-hour support and how can we guarantee
fair payments to crowd workers how can
we apply crowdsourcing to more complex
verticals such as medicine law education
design or even research itself
privileged privileged executives and
CEOs have always been relying on
assistance to help them manage their
personal information crowdsourcing has
the potential to democratize this kind
of service make it accessible and
affordable to everyone even to the crowd
workers
themselves just like a way there becomes
the restaurant client client right after
his shift a crowd worker can enjoy the
benefits of having his personal
information managed by other by the
crowd so this is a this is only possible
with crowdsourcing and it's tremendous
price reductions as it is unlikely that
the traditional personal assistant would
have the resources to pay another
personal assistant to help them with
their own tasks this way not only people
can have more time but also new forms of
job opportunities can be created to
conclude the presentation I will show
you a video from ABC and NBC News on
email valid how would you feel about a
total stranger going through your email
that's a question posed by a stanford
research project as ABC 7 News reporter
Jonathan Blum found out the answer has
everything to do with what you get in
return you probably wouldn't hand your
car keys to a total stranger unless that
stranger is a valet parking attendant in
fact some cars come with a special key
that limits what valets can do you know
that they can drive the car but they
can't open the trunk so likewise we're
thinking about what would be like to
have valet software professor Michael
Bernstein is an advisor on a graduate
research project called email valet just
like valet parking it aims to save you
time and energy by having an assistant
comb through your gmail inbox for you so
the assistant can see a limited amount
of the emails they can perform a very
limited amount of actions based on the
user's requests and they can help them
with cope with email overload PhD
student Nicholas Cocoa's created a
program where for about two dollars a
day per user and assistant who works
part-time from home can read just the
emails you want them to see and turn
your messy inbox into a tidy to-do list
if something computers just aren't good
at on their own people do a much better
job than machines
the humble creativity of negotiating
everyday life of course you can make
that to-do list yourself but the study
found people who used an assistant wound
up actually doing more of the tasks on
their list just the fact that ape asked
is there for you it uses the activation
energy to actually do the task so an
assistant can help you be extra
productive but how many people actually
want a perfect stranger going from their
email well the study found something
surprising we realize that the people
yet less concerned about privacy when
they start receiving benefits from a
system the less than four percent of
online survey respondents initially said
they share their inbox about ninety
percent of those who actually use the
service wanted to keep it sadly for them
it's still just a research project but
it could become a business there's a
little leather invested in successes
Google I think they're faking out of
this floor at Stanford Jonathan bloom
abc7 news I'll switch to the other video
at the time I finish
since about 20 million emails will have
been sent in fact people send an
estimated 145 billion emails worldwide
every day CEOs and other top executives
usually have personal assistants to
handle all the tasks buried in those
emails but what about the rest of us NBC
Barry Stephanie trong joins us with the
program when local group says will cut
that email overload Stephanie that's
right Jessica it's a concept called
crowdsourcing Wikipedia is one example
of it what it boils down to is tapping
into a large group of people for
services and content now the question
here is would you be interested in say
double it your productivity even if it
meant handing over your email password
to a total stranger from the moment you
wake up to when you're at work whether
it's under desktop or on your cell those
emails just keeps on coming and some of
it has important tasks but the more time
reading may mean less time doing and
they seem trivial but they really hold
it back CEOs and top execs have their
own solution personal assistants who dig
through emails for them managing that
onslaught but what about the rest of us
I really like to push on this team of
three from Stanford's computer science
department came up with one solution
email valet the test version used gmail
it's a program that connects you with
professionals online who become your
remote assistance they go through your
emails find the tasks and put them into
a list with the original emails just to
the left but first like you hand your
keys over to eval a you'll have to hand
over your password the group decided to
test the idea what people give strangers
access to their emails we actually
validated that it was indeed a crazy
idea PhD student Nicholas cone that says
of the six hundred people surveyed less
than four percent said they'd be willing
to give up their passwords people like
Stanford Business scribes student and
study participant Anish Patel I think
privacy is an issue but he changed his
mind after the ten days
email valet has a feature built-in where
you can restrict let the assistant sees
you can blacklist out anything that
contains particular keywords like bank
or password a credit card or anything
they also built in a tracking feature we
actually keep track of what the crowd
worker has done Patel said those
measures plus cutting the headache of
reading countless emails make this
program well worth it especially because
he said computer driven you know health
programs fell flat for him that
experimental feeling like honestly
nothing ever seemed to really stick for
me in the group study calculus says
emailed la doubled productivity compared
to those who tried to manage tasks in
emails by themselves how much would you
have to pay it's estimated the total
comes in at less than two bucks a day or
60 bucks a month that compared to a
three thousand dollar per month salary
of a real executive assistant so we've
got coca-cola started on email Valley in
the first place the idea that came after
creating a social-media gaming platform
we were measuring how much time people
spend playing the games the total more
than 1 billion minutes translated to
eight hour work days at this about 2,000
years with services like email that
light he's hoping to give people time
back he were emails and has more time to
play more days now as for the cost of
all that email Valley creators say it
would be less than two bucks a day it is
still in the very early stages they're
hoping a company will see the potential
for doubling this productivity and pick
up the project jazz and Raj how do we
set up for that haha very interesting
isn't it alright thanks Stephanie that's
big enough chief meteorologist Jeff a
very happy friday night yeah you too as
your feet how would you know again I'd
like to thank Scott for introducing me
to HCI research and for tirelessly
advising my work in this dissertation I
like to thank Mendel for his patient
advice and general supports throughout
my entire PhD career Michael for his
candid advice and help on the second
half of this thesis Monica for
here energy and support in recruiting
participants Cindy I'll fan or the CH
Attalus Greg little Wendy Makai camera
entitlement my parents and my sister for
all the thoughtful discussions love and
support throughout the years I also want
to thank the statics staff for
participating in many of the priests
studies of these theses and for bearing
with premature software and I want to
thank all desk was for being there and
for sponsoring crowd workers my finally
I want to thank my paper collaborators
my committee members and i'm sure i'm
forgetting many other people who deserve
credit thank you up and without i will
open to any questions you may have yes
here's a me ask question of privacy
question search for mrs. long-term
response they say I said to you but
you're gonna save a lot of time you
don't wash your doors you know these
Keys just go in you say I'm ever couple
with that do whatever you do ever we get
I'm getting more comfortable does it do
I trust that to say it's not really
gonna be a problem that's a very good
question we we didn't address this
problem in this faces we can't address
that easily and I think that it's a
really good question for future research
we we we helped a little bit but because
without email valid for example you
would need to give out your username and
password and what happens if they change
your password and you lose your email
completely so we we managed to alleviate
that pain but we were not able to we
can't answer things like what you just
said
how do you consider like a class or
state approach for your email handling
the Sun unique ways that you know now
there are movements can read your
e-mails extracting the past and just
show you highlights of like 10 in a
photo your 300 email they have they
contain ask them either the time so what
from also taking into account the
privacy what do you think we'd be going
forward will be the mainstream so having
a kind of agent let me try to can you
clarify what's a capsule before I killed
an engine program displays all of your
email and identified path that I'll be
fine for the indoor female RCA so
compared to letting somebody go over
like a human and do that for you yes
that's that's a very good question the
question is about comparing existing
algorithmic ways that they automatically
try to understand using machine learning
or natural language processing which of
your emails are important versus giving
access to a human to do that I would my
answer is that the difference is in the
accuracy and the quality of the response
we tried at least all of the NLP prod
projects that we could research projects
that we could find and all the programs
that we can find and there was a lot of
mistakes of those algorithms for example
they would either show you too many
tasks or too little tasks and and I
think that's the means that's the main
difference on the other hand humans have
this common sense ability to identify
what's important in what is important in
people's inboxes yes people who are
looking at your inbox we are not using
they don't have a state contest and
subsidies you make us in an important
they may not and so it takes a while
it's like your personal assistant for a
reason is your personal assistant
because it is you understand that
great bring us up to some of it after
your attention come under not that the
same thing will happen between when you
compare an automated automated approach
and we wish to the machines outside
human that's that's right that's also a
very good point so we we saw that even
in our limited studies that the
assistance over time became better and
better at managing their specific
individuals that they were helping so
and that that's probably why we saw
their they increase the sixty-five
percent of accuracy went up to
eighty-five percent by the end of the
study and we for that reason we had a
small chat functionality in the system
where you could offline leave notes to
the assistance of what you consider
important important and the assistant
could reply back by asking questions
sometimes so there was an example where
an assistant asked the user would you
like me to extract tasks from so-and-so
and the user said yes i would like to
another system replied okay because you
declined one of my tasks for him so i
just wanted to clarify so that was an
interesting conversation that we
observed and that's a that that that
raises the question of how do you
institutionalize that implicit knowledge
that happens in inside the mind of their
assistants the chat trade paper trail is
is a first step and more research needs
to be done to find even better ways for
that
so maybe we can hit the reciprocal
question Terry's so let's say that we
built an automatic vision-based your
core systems like great I promise you
that whatever you want up to your door
you know need to login whatever you want
the door to let you in whatever anyone
else lost the door it won't let them in
I my father's would be that a lot of
people still feel a little bit
uncomfortable for making that first leap
even if after they're in it that's what
you found with you la and say all this
is great and I'm going to use this more
and more so the question this suggests
is even if we build a perfect system
right with assistance or automatic or
whatever the stir this leap people have
to make to share their inbox I'm
wondering can you think of any ways that
we can really make that that leap a
little bit less scary people I don't get
them to make that first meeting trust
resistance that's right when we see that
in many of the systems out there that
there is always a mini version of what
what they're offering and and that that
hooks you in and then after you are
hooked in then you get to see the whole
depth of the system and this is a pretty
standard in game design so in the
beginning one and two of the games you
see only limited functionality and you
get a small reward from it and over time
it becomes more complex and you get more
benefit out of it so system designers
can come up with simple solutions that
require much less giving up of privacy
from the users to start to get them on
and then once they are on then they can
ask for more privacy and ask for more
private data I feel comfortable sharing
oh yes yes
for example for example that yes or
creating a plug-in that allows you to
screen capture an email that's that's
sitting in in front of your screen so
without a without giving access to your
full inbox to the system and then and
then little by little getting you to to
use it yes here's a necklace interesting
direction which is in any kind of
security mechanisms there's always
analysis what is the threat well as his
word have you mentioned particular if I
gave my password this person could lock
me out of my account that's one kind of
threat they can do all sorts of other
stuff for the password to in a non
password situation what is your sense of
the threat model of things that could go
bad if they did many things could go bad
for example as a computer scientists in
in the beginning of this project we're
thinking that the most important feature
that we would want to have is a system
that automatically changes names or I
trying two tries to find credit card
numbers or passwords or other things in
the emails and that it translates those
to something else maybe a temporary
other name only used for the for the
human assistant to see and we were
impressed when we saw that users didn't
even have didn't really have those
concerns but i think that these are very
valid concerns and approaches like this
need to be created so the challenges of
doing research aims domain hmm yes
that's a very weak or something Scott so
personal people are used to existing
tools and practices in personal
information management they have their
own favorite email clients task lists
and these are created by big companies
so they are full-featured and they have
nice icons so if you want to create to
do research on these systems then you
either have to create your own or to try
to
back into existing ones which may be
difficult maybe especially in our cases
gmail wasn't giving us the ability to to
do what we wanted to do and if you
create your own then you get the side
effects so users don't want to use them
until they look they are polished enough
to be able to replace their favorite
email client even just for a week so so
yes it's a pretty challenging field
people actually send each other class
and start sending each other email right
how do you think was that email valid in
confessed that hypothetical sister like
you and what's supposed to discipline it
of creating of fun using this is a this
would be a good feature for introducing
more people for example to involve a leg
so you create a task for yourself or you
and you can also create a task for
someone else and click about and send it
to someone the challenge here is that
the other person that if the other
person doesn't have the software then
that they won't be able to see what you
sent them so in that respect is good
because they will see a link that says
install the software start start using
my ballet but but it doesn't really
solve the problem of the program that
you are describing because of because
that system is not ubiquitous yet it's
not something that everybody has but but
email is a general purpose tool that
everyone has it has yes does is it add
structure to gmail one reason that email
overload is so painful is that you get
this big pile of completely unstructured
stuff that you need to deal with in some
way and Dave receipt isn't a very
meaningful me piece of metadata and
there have been other systems that have
tried to add structure on to email with
varying degrees of
success life Terry's communicator from
several huge back what's your thought on
how your work compares to that so that's
a first the practical step towards that
direction it's a the communicator and
other similar ideas are really really
fantastic the the only reason why they
were not adopted this the work they're
not used every day today it's just
because they failed on the adoption so
you need to have everyone using it to be
able to get all the benefits them from
it so that's why I think that we have to
start from tools that people already use
and try to make those tools better
another detail brush it with task genies
work move your studies we were saying
that you helped both with lingering
tasks and with high level tasks I'm
wondering what's the correlation between
those two I think in particular is this
loading on the same construct really
most of the stuff that's lingering on my
to-do did to do this is high level yes
we we have this number on your paper I
think it is 0.6 i'm told remember but
yes there isn't it but it's a pretty
considerable correlation between those
two yes or you can still imagine that
the maybe tasks that are one kind but
not together all right thank you very
much
you